The specific objectives
of this lesson are for
us to look at how are we
going to transform the image?
specifically transformations
like Rigid Transformations.
Specifically Translation and Rotation.
Again, the emphasis is that we
are trying to do now is look inside
the image but not at the intensities,
but the number of rows and columns.
The number of pixels in the image and
transform those.
An additional part of it, where we will
also look at non-rigid transformations,
where we would actually look at our
final projective transformations.
But more importantly, what we
want to do now is start looking at,
how many numbers, how many parameters,
degrees of freedom we
want to be able to model in mathematics
of how to do these transformations.
So, let's get started.